Hi everyone it's Charlie! You've probably seen
the news Robert Pattinson is apparently
going to be our next Batman in Matt
Reeves the Batman trilogy or however
many movies he winds up doing so there's
a whole bunch of stuff going on about
this I know you want to know what the
movie is supposed to be about and why
they're going with Robert Pattinson why
Ben Affleck isn't going to be the Batman
of Matt Reeves movies so we'll break it
down no worries naturally as you'd
expect reactions are all over the place
anytime there's a new Batman everybody
freaks out for better or for worse so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Batman and DC
videos remember Comic Con is happening
this summer we're going to get a whole
bunch more trailers and we'll find out
what's going on with the rest of the
Justice League characters including the
flash and probably Superman as well so
big news last night variety was
reporting that Robert Pattinson has been
selected as the next Batman for Matt
Reeves trilogy there were a lot of other
news outlets that were also saying that
the studio was considering Nicholas
Hoult and they haven't completely
settled on who it's going to be but
variety is usually pretty solid with
their scoops so unless they come out in
the next couple of days and say
otherwise I'm assuming that Robert
Pattinson is going to be our next Batman
I know the first thing you're thinking
is is a wait a minute that Twilight
vampire guy that sparkles is going to be
our next Batman what's up with that
Robert Pattinson has actually done a lot
of really solid work post Twilight and
if you really do hate those Twilight
movies I guarantee you that Robert
Pattinson hates them more than you this
is a short montage of him hating the
Twilight movies in a bunch of different
interviews that'll make you feel a
little bit better about him did your
Twilight experience turn out to be what
you expected oh when I read it it seemed
like wasn't it was like it was a book
that wasn't supposed to be published
definitely something wrong with her and
there's very obviously something wrong
with me
I was convinced that Stephanie was
convinced she was Bella and when
especially when she says I was based on
a dream and it's like oh I had this
dream by this really sexy guy and she
just writes his book about it it's like
this woman is mad so now that we've
established that Robert Pattinson hates
the Twilight movies as much as you what
is the story of his movie going to be
how old is he going to be how are they
going to associate him with the other
Justice League characters in present day
because this is supposed to be a prequel
that's why they cast an actor that was
so young the interesting thing though is
that Christian Bale I think was 31 when
he was cast to be Batman in Batman
Begins in right now Robert Pattinson is
33 so he's older than Christian Bale
when Christian Bale became Batman right
now the period of this first movie is
supposed to be somewhere around Batman
year one period Matt Reeves defined it
as a story that would define who he was
going forward so it's just a really epic
thing that happens to him early in his
career that completely changes him going
forward
last year insiders were calling Matt
Reeves script a version of Batman mask
of the phantasm with a few of the
characters swapped and Batman mask of
the phantasm is one of the best Batman
movies of all time it just happens to be
animated so if you're going to crib from
other Batman stories that's one of the
better ones to do
Matt Reeves said he wanted to take the
franchise back to a very classic place
so it's meant to be Batman the world's
greatest detective is going to be a
detective neo noir thriller the thing
about modern Batman films is that with
the Christian Bale films as awesome as
the Dark Knight trilogy is Batman turned
into more of a big action spectacle film
with a lot of toys and a lot of big
explosions all over the place they kept
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
when we got to Zack Snyder it got even
bigger and bigger and further and
further away from his roots as a
detective so Matt Reeves is taking him
back to that so obviously it's going to be
a complete re imagining of what the
franchise looks like the look and feel
as well as the cape and cowl the
characters everything from the ground up
is going to be re imagined your follow up
question then is why isn't Ben Affleck
going to be Batman in Matt Reeves movie
because it would be pretty easy for them
to do a detective movie with Ben Affleck
Ben Affleck actually gave the answer to
that himself
they said that basically there were two
competing versions of the movie there
was the ben affleck geoff johns script
that he was working on the past couple
of years while he was doing his zack
snyder films i'll play the clip of him
talking about it in a second but per his
explanation he just couldn't come up
with a version of the movie that he felt
was really exciting really compelling it
that the studio liked
I've read and I've seen announcements to
the effect of that you will not read you
will not be Batman again I am yeah I
have decided to thank you thank you very
much yeah you know I tried to direct a
version of it and worked with the really
good screenwriter but just kind of
couldn't come up with a version that
couldn't crack it and so I thought it
was like you know time to let someone
else take a shot at they got some really
good people
so we unofficially passed the baton to
Matt Reeves Matt Reeves version
obviously as I said is world's greatest
detective Batman it's completely
different take on the character and it's
a prequel so it's a much younger version
of the character moving forward now I
know your next question is who's the
main villain of this new Batman film
Matt Reeves actually revealed that there
will be a number of Batman's rogues
gallery villains in the movie but early
rumors were that the penguin would be
the main villain they have to do a lot
of world building for whatever this new
version of Gotham is going to look like so
just expect a lot of Batman's core
villains to pop up through the film next
big question what about his Selina Kyle
Catwoman she didn't show up anywhere
during any of the recent DCEU films she
might actually be
showing up somewhere during the Matt
Reeves films because she was not cast
for the birds-of-prey movie that movie's
supposed to be a girl gang of pseudo
antihero characters Catwoman is probably
the biggest female antihero from the
Batman comics next to Harley Quinn I
will go so far to say is the Catwoman is
even less of a villain and more of a
hero than Harley Quinn usually when huge
characters like that are not cast in
films that seem very appropriate for
them is because they're bookmarked for
other films so don't be surprised if she
winds up showing up somewhere in this
Matt Reeves film but I know the next
question after that is his will Robert
Pattinson also play Batman in the next
Justice League movie won't that be weird
if they only recast some of a DCEU
Justice League characters from the last
film so what he'll probably happen is
that he would have to sign a 3 to 5
picture deal for a trilogy of Matt
Reeves Batman films and then potentially
a couple other crossover films way down
the line but recently as part of the big
shake-up is the way they're changing
this universe is that Warner Brothers
said that it's going to be a long time
before they do another Justice League
movie so don't be surprised if we get
two or three Matt Reeves Batman movies
before you see them do another Justice
League film really good example of how
fast their timeline is moving is that
the Aquaman sequel is not going to happen
for another three and a half years that
is a glacially slow pace so for the most
part all the different DC films are
allowed to be their own thing with very
very loose crossover and references to
the other characters within the film's
Wonder Woman 1984 in the Aquaman movie
are great examples of that Wonder Woman
set during the past so obviously no big
characters are going to cross over into
that Aquaman referenced a couple of
Justice League things from the events of
that movie but you didn't see any other
big Justice League characters show up
during it defeated Steppenwolf and saved
Atlantis
that had nothing to do with Atlantis so
that is the level of crossover that
we're going for and then you ask what
about the flash movie I'll talk about
that in a second too because what's
happening this summer at comic-con is
they're probably going to  drop the full
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer because that
movies coming out next year and Ezra
Miller really does seem like he's going to
be out as the flash but if I win you're
off the team
you probably heard the story about how
they were giving him a chance to write a
version of the movie with Grant Morrison
DC also hired the Spider Man far from
home guys to direct the movie and to
write it so right now Ezra Miller is
competing with them for his script in
the film and people are saying that it's
just his bid to try and stay on as the
flash before they recast him it's
getting really good it's getting really
good enough you know anyone who knows
anything about Barry Allen knows that
he's always late but then when he
arrives he gets stuff done and that's
definitely how this film's production
schedule was proceeding we're a little
late but we're really you know the
reason why we're late and this is the
honest-to-god truth is the reason why
we're late is because we're all and I
include myself in this we are very
meticulously focused on making a movie
that's not just like one of the greatest
superhero movies that we can possibly
make this movie is also going to be a gift
to the fans you know this movie this
movie's going to be a real pure offering to
the fans of this material and we've hit
a couple points in the scripts
development where we've looked at it and
gone this isn't it this isn't it yet it
has to be and you know we're really
we're starting about we're talking about
sparking a whole new universe which is
it's not just the DC X multiverse it's
also it's the speedster multiverse the
version of the movie the Ezra Miller
wants to make is more in the vein of the
Zack Snyder universe dark flashpoint the
version of the movie that the Spider Man
homecoming people are wanting to make
a little bit more on the vena back to
the future it's a little bit brighter
like Wonder Woman 1984 in Aquaman
so obviously DC is going in a much
brighter direction so I just do not
expect them to pick Azra miller script
over the other script but officially
they haven't commented on that recently
so we probably won't find out about that
till the summer but I do think they're
going to recast Ezra Miller because they
want to start shooting the Flash movie
towards the end of this year early next
year we still don't know what's going to
happen with Superman in the Man of Steel
franchise obviously they're going to
continue to make more Superman films but
I'm not expecting to hear any kind of
news about that before the end of this
year but they'll probably some rumors
going on and Henry Cavill is obviously
doing The Witcher franchise I'll be
doing episode videos for that but I
believe that's not going to premiere till
December so just expect a lot of Henry
Cavill news to be happening later this
year let me know in the comments with
all your reactions about this what do
you think about the way they're changing
the universe about the idea of them
doing a world's greatest detective
Batman franchise in the vein of mask of
the phantasm when we get more updates I
will do more videos about that but
obviously we have crisis on Infinite
Earths
happening on the TV shows I'll do a
teaser trailer video for that this
weekend so just look out for that while
you wait for everything click here for
my Game of Thrones finale trailer video
and click here for my Avengers endgame
deleted scenes videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight!